you like yachts
yes what pretty lady don't like yachts
nancy you like yachts sure when's the
last time you were on a yacht
uh just uh the vault count as a yacht
yeah yeah
was the last time you were on a yacht
every weekend
oh yeah you're not going to be in a
little dinky though
wait how do you think we got over here
well played she's quick all right so
shifting from cars to yachts are you
familiar with the metaverse is this
familiar with what's going on in the
metaverse yes how about you nancy
metaverse are you familiar with this
well the a virtual mega yacht was just
sold for a record-breaking 908 thousand
dollars in the metaverse let me repeat
this is a virtual yacht
okay that's sold in the virtual
marketplace of the metaverse you
physically can't go on this yacht okay
and it sold for just a shade under
a cool million bucks so here's the story
so the meta flower
uh super mega yacht the meta flower
that's a play on words from i assume the
mayflower where the pilgrims came over
which was a probably not a yacht uh was
sold for 149 ethereum coins which is the
equivalent of nine hundred and eight
thousand dollars this is the most
expensive nft token ever sold in the
virtual
gaming world all right so on the super
yacht there's a dj booth for the dj put
your hands up
there's a helicopter landing pad for
your fake helicopter and there's a hot
tub for you to fake jump in and you know
put on your fake bathing suit okay
so the meta the metaflower exists in the
sandbox metaverse collection of nfts you
familiar with nfts
yes but what does that have to do
on it what is that i don't even know
nancy
token non-fudge but boom just dropped
the microphone non-fungible token okay
um
sandbox is one of the leading metaverse
worlds and has done collabs with
everyone from snoop dogg to dead mouse
that's for that dj booth that exists on
this virtual mega yacht can we see a
picture of the mega yacht right there
can you maybe scroll up
okay there's the mega or what about the
actual article
go back to that scroll and i'll scroll
up the other way
there it is there's your yacht jenny
let's go get some sun scroll up a little
bit more
there you go
there's your yacht that's where you're
gonna get your tan there's the
helicopter party with snoop dogg there's
your helicopter pad your helipad you can
see there's the there's the hot tub
there's the blue thing in the front
and uh you know obviously there's a dj
booth in there anywho so just real quick
before we talk about yachts and all this
what are you guys thoughts on
the metaverse i know you're not meta
experts but nancy you're a smart gal
what are your thoughts on the metaphors
i think it's cool
like
virtual world it's kind of another way
of how people can connect with each
other like for instance like i just
moved from dallas so my way of
connecting with all my friends back
there is face timing if i could just put
on some goggles and then we can just
hang out together that's like a whole
nother boom you're putting on some
goggles now you're on this yacht having
the time of your life yeah
good point jenny metaverse you got any
strong feelings on this i feel it's how
you use it
with technology in general you know it
could be an asset or not however i don't
agree with like
you just spent almost a mil on this fake
yacht
like you're living a fake life so what
i'm going to sit at home
and wear my goggles and just
live in this fantasy life for the rest
of my life yeah
with snoop dogg turning up in my bikini
in my
bam bamming body now i don't even have
to get surgery right like you just you
just you don't have to chill
to get ready i could be out here i could
be like this like what's up over there
i'm banging i have fake romances on
there yeah
there's no commitment you don't have to
meet up with them in person you just
meet them on this yacht right there yeah
so that's so you're going would you go
on a meta yacht date was that something
you said even you're comfortable with or
is that kind of weird
sorry the fact that even the question
exactly this is where we're at in 2022
would you go on a date on this meta yeah
jenny
jenny hot jenny from the block over here
are you ready to go on a metadate i'm
going to take you on my house negative
you better pick me up from my house are
we better meet up in person i need human
connection i don't need no fake and it
better not being a freaking mini cooper
bro well this goes into location right
because florida is pretty much open and
i imagine this happens in places that
are still shut down okay so a lot of
like virtual dates are probably more
common in california and new york but do
you really have to go to the met let's
say you do a virtual date like i did
long distance for a while when i was in
a relationship so there was a lot of
like facetime sessions you know
i feel like you can just
pick up the phone or zoom and do that
way then have to like go into a
metaverse and like explore i don't guys
this is the future i'm not sure if you
understand you know that facebook just
changed their name to metal oh you know
they changed their names i'm adapting to
this you know mark zuckerberg ain't no
idiot he understands that the future of
dating is on meta yachts
okay
speaking of mark zuckerberg is there any
amount of money that you would sleep
with mark zuckerberg
he's in the asians by the way he's
married to an asian
any amount of money like you don't care
how rich is you wouldn't
i don't know i can't imagine that
climbing on top of you
no
no nothing no no this is what you're
saying this goes back into my anxiety
like i couldn't go through with it i'd
probably throw up or something
i wouldn't even do it for free nothing
no okay so mark well for free obviously
would you do it for money no i wouldn't
even do it for free even though i got
the free thing i get it but for the
money
i wouldn't do it for free either jenny i
would do it for money
[Music]